[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد يبدو ان التيار الوطني
الحر برئاسه النائب اللبناني جبرل باسيل
قد اقفل الابواب امام ما يوصف بتسويه يتم
العمل عليها في غرف سياسيه مغلقه للتوصل
الى اسماء توافقيه للرئاسه بين باسيل وحزب
الله صحيفه شرق الاوسط اشارت الى ان
الانفصال بين الفريقين قد اصبح امرا واقعا
بعد 17 عاما على توقيع اتفاق مرمخايل الذي
كرس تحالفا بين الطرفين سنوات التحالف
شهدت خلافات بين نصر الله وبين التيار حول
قضايا عده لكنها لم تصل الى المرحله التي
وصلت اليها اليوم بعد او من التصعيد على
خلفيه الانتخابات الرئاسيه اخرها كان ما
صدر عن بسيل مؤخرا حين هجم الحزب ضمنيا
بسبب الخلاف على دعم الحزب للنائب السابق
سليمان فرنجيه وفق الصحيفه فيما ردت مصادر
مقربه من ان شاء الله بان التيار هو الذي
بدا حملته على نصر الله وعلى فريقه معتبره
ان التيار يريد فك التحالف
[موسيقى]
صدع في العلاقه التحالفيه بين حزب الله
والتيار الوطني الحر مرحله دقيقه يمر بها
الحليفان منذ توقيعهما على ورقه التفاهم
في فبراير 2006 حزب الله حصر الخلافات
والنقاش الداخليه مع جبران باسيل في
الاجتماعات المغلقه بينما باسيل اعلن عن
موقفه الرافض لمرشح حزب الله للرئاسه
فرنجيه في العالم
مصادر لبنانيه باسيل قرر الدخول في مواجهه
سياسيه مباشره مع نصر الله مصادر لبنانيه
العلاقات بين باسيل وحزب الله انكسرت ولا
مجالا لترميمها مصادر لبنانيه علاقه باسيل
بحليفه حزب الله يمكن ان تصبح جزءا من
الماضي بعد ان تخطى الخطوط الحمر
مساء الخير هو مسلسل ابتزاز مستمر يقوم به
جبران باسيل تجاهز بالله هذا التحالف
الجهنمي ما بين التيار الوطني الحر وحزب
الله قد اودى بعد 17 عاما الى مجموع
الماسي والازمات التي يعاني منها الشعب
اللبناني اليوم ولسوء الحظ الخلاف اليوم
بين التيار الوطني الحر وبين حزب الله
وليس خلاف مبدئي واما ولكن هو خلاف على
الحصص وخلاف على الرئاسه وخلاف على من
سيدعم من اعتقد بان سقف هذا الخلاف سوف
يبقى مضبوط لان التحالف ما بين المافيا
والمليشيا بحاجه الى بعضها البعض كي تستمر
اليوم يقوم به جبران باسيل
وهذا واضح من خلال عدم الجديه في التعاطي
مع جلسات انتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه لو كان
هنالك قرار حقيقي وفعلي في
انهاء التحالف بين
الوطني الحر وحزب الله لراينا وجود داخل
اسوار المجلس النيابي وتصويت لشخصيه
واعطاء موقف واضح وصريح تجاه الانتخابات
النيابيه انتخابات الرئاسيه الحاليه ما
يحصل اليوم هو شتحبال من اجل تحسين الشروط
ومحاوله جرح حزب الله الى مكان يجبر من
خلاله جبران باسيل بالتخلي على سليمان
الفرنجيه تحت ستار ضروره ابقاء التحالف ما
بين فريق مسيحي ومكون اخر شيعي وبالتالي
المحافظه على التحالف ما بين المافيا
والميليشيا ولكن شد الحبل والاستمرار في
شده قد ينهك هذا الحبل وقد يتسبب في قطعه
كذلك وهنا سؤال سيد مالك هل تعتقد بان ما
نتابعه هو سحابه صيف كما يقول البعض او
انه انفصال حقيقي بعد 17 عاما من الشراكه
السياسيه خاصه اذا ما استمرت ما اسماه سيد
جاد ابتزاز لجبران
مساء الخير اهلا بك يا سيدتي لا لا شك ان
هناك ان الوضع بين الوضع بين التيار
وحزب الله هو غير ايجابي ولكنه اعطى غير
انه غير سلبي حتى الان لان الخلاف محصور
حاليا بملفين الملف الاول هو الموقف من
انتخابات رئاسه الجمهوريه والموقف من
الحكومه اللبنانيه من الحكومه الحاليه
واجتماعات هذا ما فجر الخلاف انا اعتقد
وهو هذا ما اظهر التباينات بهذا الملف
بقيه النقاط على المواضيع الاقليميه
والمواضيع الارهاب واسرائيل هو هي موضوع
تفاهم وموضوع اتفاق تامر حتى الان هناك
نظره مختلفه هناك اختلاف بوجهه النظر بين
التيار وتنحر كما يبدو وبين وبين حزب الله
اما موضوع الابتزاز ما ذكره الزميل الكريم
كلها تدخل ضمن اللعبه السياسيه التي تمارس
ليس في لبنان تمارس في دول العالم بين
الاطراف السياسيه للتحالفات السياسيه تحصل
على المواقع انت قلتها بين الاطراف ليس
بين الحلفاء نعم
الاطراف الحلفاء الحلفاء يا سيدتي كانوا
اطراف قبل ان يعقدوا تحالفاتهم وعندما
تنفصل هذه التحالفات يعودون اطراف هذا هذا
ما يحصل في كل دول العالم هناك احزاب
سياسيه تتصارع وتتفق على مواضيع وتختلف عن
المواضيع نحن القوات اللبنانيه اختلفنا
اتفقنا على على برنامج معين وحصل طلاق
سياسي في هذا الموضوع ماذا جرى القوات
اللبنانيه بقيت في موقعها ونحن بقينا في
موقعنا واذا حصل ان تحالف التيار وتنحر
والقوات اللبنانيه وحزب
لم يعد لم يعد صلبا على مواضيع سياسيه
داخليه قد يكون هذا قد يكون هذا بدايه
بدايه لاعاده تموضع كان للقوى لحزب الله
او او
هذا مشروع ماذا ماذا ما هو ما هو
الغريب في الموضوع تخالف 14 ادوار بني على
اسس دوليه واقليميه وماليه
واستقطابيه كبيره منذ 2005 ولكنه تفجر في
بدايه 2010 وحتى الان لم تستطع اي قوه في
العالم من اعاده لملمته ماذا حصل للاطراف
كل طرف بقي على مواقفه والحياه السياسيه
مهتمه
هل تعتبر كضيفي بان هذه حركه عاديه هكذا
هي الحياه السياسيه وهكذا هي الترتيبات
السياسيه وهناك امكانيه لاعاده موضوع لهذه
الاطراف ام ان تاريخ وحاضر وتقارب الطرفين
قد ياخذنا لصفحه اخرى قد يفهمنا امور اخرى
سيدتي العزيزه الحياه السياسيه اللبنانيه
لا يحكمها المنطق وهذا ما تجلى من خلال
الحاله الماساويه التي يعيشها لبنانيون
اليوم ومجموع الماسي والازمات الاجتماعيه
الاقتصاديه الماليه السياسيه النقديه
القضائيه الصحيه الى اخره اليوم يحصل هو
تخلي المسؤولين عن مسؤولياتهم لبنان في
ازمه الشعب اللبناني في ازمه هنالك فراغ
رئاسي وما زلنا نتحدث عن فريقين هناك ولكن
الاساسيتين
المجموعه الحاكمه في الفتره الماضيه
وبالتالي تحالفهما ادى الى هذه الازمه
واليوم اشد الحبال الذي يكمان به ايضا
يؤدي الى استمرار الازمه ولا يؤدي الى اي
حل في المدى المنصور حضرتك سيد جاد منذ
قليل تحدثت وقلت ب هناك وكان
تخلي هناك من تخلى عن الشعب اللبناني ولكن
خلينا في اطار الطرفين من تخلى عن الاخر
هل حزب الله هو الذي تخلى عن التيار الحر
بعدم تمكينه من
مرشح محتمل وذهب ودعم سليمان الفرنجيه ام
العكس تيار الحر هو الذي بدا بهذه
التصريحات وبدا في عمليه التخلي على حزب
الله
انها مشاكل بين البيت الواحد لا يمكن لي
بان اكرر من هو الذي تخلى عن الثاني ولكن
ما اعتقد وما اراه بان هذه المجموعه وهذا
الفريق السياسي ليس بامكانه بان يقدم
للبنانيين اي شيء ايجابي لا بتحالفه ولا
به الخصومه فيما بينهما اليوم المطلوب
التحلي بالمسؤوليه الترفع عن هذه
المصالح والذهاب نحو انقاص اللبنانيين لا
اعتقد بان الشعب اللبناني اليوم يهتم لاي
فريق يخاصم اي فريق الانتخابات النيابيه
الاخيره افرزت مجموعه جديده وافرزت اغلبيه
ان كان مسيحيه او وطنيه واضحه وصريحه ما
نراه اليوم هو فريق سياسي عينه الوطني
الحر حزب الله حركه امل وحلفائهم هم من لا
يقترعون لاي مرشح في الانتخابات
العاقبه التي تحصل داخل المجلس النيابي
وهم من يعطلون الشعب اللبناني لا يعنيه ان
كان هنالك خلاف بين حزب الله والتيار وطني
الحر ما يعنيه بان لا يتحمل نتائج هذا
الخلاف وهذا ما يحصل اليوم وما هي نتائج
هذه الخلافات سيد مالك بحسب قراءتك ليس
فقط على هذا التحالف لان الانقسام سيضعف
المكون في العموم ولكن
تداعيات هذه الخلافات كذلك على اللبنانيين
لسيدتي الخلافات هي هي نتيجه
لممارسات جميع الاطراف اللبنانيه وليس فقط
التيار الوطني الطيار وحزب الله الحياه
السياسيه في لبنان والاطراف السياسيه هي
من تمارس قبل العام وقبل عام 2010 و2009
لم يكن للتيار الوطن حر اي وجود في الدوله
اللبنانيه وكانت الخلافات هي هي انا اقول
انا انا نحن نتحدث عن تحالف يحكم في فرق
التحالف التحالف الذي كان الذي كان يربط
بالله يتعرض الان
ليتعرض الان الى الى تجربه قويه هذه
التجربه قد تطيح به وقد تعود اللحمه وقد
تعود اللحمه الى لو كان تاروت الحر لا
يملك تمثيلا قويا ولا يستطيع ان يؤثر في
مجرى الاحداث السياسيه لكانت حصلت
انتخابات ولا كان حزب الله استطاع ان ان
ياتي بمرشح لرئاسه جمهوريه ان انا اسال هل
الحياه السياسيه هي فقط مسؤوليه التيار
الحر
وحزب الله ام هي مسؤوليه بقيه بقيه
الاطراف تقول انها انت استاذ مالك المنطق
يقول بان المسؤوليه
الحكم التيار الوطن الحر التيار الوطن
الحر ترك الحكم ترك الحكم منذ تشرين الاول
2022 ماذا يحصل الان من يستلم الحكم الان
لماذا هي الاطراف هل يستطيع الاطراف
الثانيه التي تدعى انها لها تمثيل شعبي
كبير هل تستطيع ديمقراطيا ان تاتي برئيس
جمهوريه لماذا لا تفعل الا يوجد خلافات
بين نواب التغيير الا يوجد خلافات بين 14
اذار بين القوات اللبنانيه
والاشتراكي الا يوجد خلافات تعليق لك
استاذ جاد باختصار شديد لو سمحت ان كان لك
تعليق على ما قيل
باختصار جديد اليوم الصراع هو داخل اسوار
المجلس النيابي بهذه المجموعه الحاكمه
التي
تفضلت بها الطير وطني الحر وحزب الله هما
من يعطلان نصاب الجلسات المطالحين في
المجلس النيابي وبالتالي هما من يتحمل جزء
من المسؤوليه بعدم الوصول الى انتخاب رئيس
جمهوريه صحيح بان كافه من المسؤوليه هي
التي عليها ان تنتخب رئيس جمهوريه ولكن في
الوقت عينه هنالك فريق ينزل الى المجلس
النيابي لديه مرشح يقترع يبقى داخل القاعه
فيما هنالك فريق ثاني الخلافات داخل فريقه
لا تؤدي الى تزكيه اي مرشح ينسحب من
الجلسات في الدوره الثانيه وبالتالي يفقد
النصاب الشعب اللبناني لا يمكن بان يستمر
بتحمل هذه الصراعات فلنحتكم الى
الديمقراطيه وليذهب الجميع نحو المجلس
النيابي ولي رئيس الجمهوريه بدل التلهي
بمن هو السبب في المشكل الوطني
مالك ابي نادر